do you really believe that there is life  out there it actually doesn't matter  what I believe this is science it  matters what I can prove if I told you I  knew the answer that would be religion  and not science what I can find through  scientific exploration does matter what  do you want to find well it's a big  question and I'd like to know what other  ways there are to make a biology and to  make a technology or is us and what  happened here the only way it can  manifest seems unlikely don't know the  answer to that I mean our tools are  getting better all the time bigger  telescopes we're building all kinds of  spacecraft for exploration we've got the  Rovers on Mars that are caching Rock  samples to be picked up later and to be  showing that Mars was wet and warm and  salty might have been a place where life  could get started